a local daca recipient is hopeful after
reading a recent twitter post from our
brand
new president and it could be life
changing christian casadas
reports well daca recipients can't seem
to stop smiling over a possible brighter
future after president joe biden
recently tweeted this he said dreamers
are american and i want them to know
that they have an
advocate and an ally with me in the
white house that's why i took immediate
action to fortify daca
during his first day president biden
signed an executive order to safeguard
the deferred action
for childhood arrivals program which
offers work permits and deportation
protection
to more than 640 000 undocumented
immigrants brought to the u.s
as children some dreamers are hopeful
that this new administration
could grant them more protection from
the immigration system or even
citizenship
it would be definitely incredible news
if we were to have
an immigration reform uh that would give
dreamers a path to citizenship
i've been in this country for 29 years
this year without legal status and it
would just be it would alter my entire
life
according to dream big nevada there are
more than 14 000 daca recipients right
here in
nevada last december immigration
approved several applications for the
program
after the trump administration tried to
eliminate it but failed
three big nevada tells me they are doing
two virtual workshops per week
free of charge to keep the community
informed we have a link to
on our website christian
eightnewsnow.com
8 news now